[Music]
halloween is tomorrow so to celebrate
tarik and i dressed up
i'm shonoff the shogun of harlem from
the movie
barry gordy's the last dragon and i'm
bruce leroy
the last dragon in the last dragon the
last dragon is one of my favorite movies
and
i've wanted to be shown up for halloween
every halloween
my entire life this is my dream
my dream is to never have to wear this
again this year because of the
coronavirus
pandemic most people won't be
trick-or-treating which is going to make
it hard to get into the halloween spirit
but we love halloween so tarek and i
would like to sing you a fun little song
about all my favorite scary monsters to
get you in the mood
it's a very spooky season a very spooky
fright
with very spooky creatures creeping in
the night
they walk along the ground and they fly
up in the air
pay attention close there are monsters
everywhere
monsters monsters mobsters everywhere
pay attention
there are monsters everywhere
that's right don't think those
frightening freaks have hidden away this
year
there are still plenty of monsters to be
found or rather
that will be finding you that's right
for instance
rude little trolls that are watching
over bridges
giant green dragons wizards and witches
frankenstein's monsters
mummies in their tomb remember coming
wolves when they gaze upon the moon
zombies rising up and feasting on your
brains
that's becoming vampires to bite you
with their fangs
phantoms floating freely in the walls
and in the floor and white women who
watch me as i walk throughout a store
monsters monsters monsters everywhere
pay attention clothes there are monsters
everywhere
you think i don't know what you're doing
asking me if you can help me find
anything
five times in 10 minutes please and no
offense but if i'm gonna risk going to
jail for shoplifting i'm not doing it at
a burlington coat factory
[Music]
serpents from the sky above krakens from
the sea
goblins and ghouls and giant living
trees bigfoot in the forest and the yeti
in the snow
guys who still say gay as if it's 30
years ago
aliens who come to earth inside a
foreign ship and anyone who goes to eat
and never leaves a tip
monsters who have 20 heads east with 20
eyes a lady who says you should really
try a larger size
monsters monsters monsters everywhere
pay attention girls there are mothers
everywhere
i don't need a larger size i've been
wearing the same pants
for like five years and coming to the
same store i know my butt
don't tell me what size pants i need to
wear miss burlington coat factory
oh damn it is the same woman chilling
little puppets terrifying clowns
massive lizard beasts stomping all over
the town creepy black birds swooping
suddenly and eerily
friends you went to school with sharing
q anon conspiracies freaky fulter guys
who live inside your tv
men who say brother when they only talk
to me robots that gain consciousness
and suddenly go crazy people who don't
vote because they're very
lazy devil men with giant knives lizard
men with scales or normal men who keep
addressing women as females
men who are invisible or powerful or
taller look
if we're being honest almost any man at
all people calling cops on children
selling lemonade
who ever made adulting into something
people say
crawling little spiders and bewitching
little sirens and people who keep
partying throughout the corona virus
don't look at us you all know exactly
who you are
monsters monsters monsters everywhere
pay
go
[Music]
[Applause]
you